Speaker 1: One of my favorite things is when the
conspiracy theorists agree about the conspiracy,
but with conflicting evidence to support it.
This happens with flat earthers all the time.
You've got flat earthers who believe the earth is
flat, but they will prove, quote, prove the earth
is flat with contradictory.
Speaker 2: Quote,
evidence. And one of them has to be wrong.
Speaker 1: And I just absolutely love it.
And we have an example from CPAC.
Speaker 2: As many of you know,
one of the big lie.
Speaker 1: Election conspiracy theories is that
part of how Democrats.
Speaker 2: Quote, cheat is with early.
Speaker 1: Voting and mail in voting. And
so there's a lot of Republicans who say.
Speaker 2: We just we've got to have one day of.
Speaker 1: Voting. And if you're a Republican.
Speaker 2: Definitely.
Speaker 1: Vote on Election Day
so that they don't mess with your vote.
Speaker 2: But there are others.
Speaker 1: In the Republican Party
who are now realizing, wait a second,
if the Democrats vote early and by mail.
Speaker 2: And we don't, they get like three
weeks of voting and we get one day, that's not
good. So here we have a clip of Steve Bannon and
Mypillow CEO Mike Lindell interviewing, being
interviewed, whatever. And it starts to happen
that there's this disagreement. Wait, are we?
Is the problem that we're not voting early or
should we or not? This is this is just absolute
gold of the it's an example of the mayonnaise.
Speaker 1: That their brains
have been turned into.
Speaker 3: So do you think voting yes, Steve,
we're going to get wiped out again? You cannot
give the Democrats 55 days to vote and we have
15 hours. There is no mathematical equation
that is going to win you an election.
It's great to talk about. It's fun. You
get fired up. They've got 55 days to get
ballots in and we're giving ourselves 15
hours. If we continue this, we'll never win again.
Speaker 2: Now, I don't think this guy's wrong in
the sense that. There is no voter fraud the way.
Speaker 1: They claim there is.
Speaker 2: And if you do restrict
yourself only to the people who can vote.
Speaker 1: On Election Day, whereas Democrats are
saying I'll vote when it's convenient, if there's
early voting, I'll do that or I'll mailing by.
Speaker 2: Ballot. You are hurting
yourself. That is true.
Speaker 4: But is it? Isn't that
what they did to Carrie Lake? We had they.
Speaker 5: Say that's why they had to turn
the machines off, Steve. And if they
do it the way John said, you know,
he's just misconstrued, you can over run an
algorithm and you can't overrun a computer.
You have to do it the way I'm telling you.
Speaker 1: I like the woman in the back,
nodding as if she has any idea what
Pillow's talking about. Hold it, Hold it.
Speaker 4: Here's what I propose in the world.
Do it, RV. We have to have a debate on our
side of the football because there's clearly two
camps and your camps probably 6535. But we need
everybody 100% on one or the other because
this is critical. So we commit that we're
going to do this where we get everybody.
Speaker 5: Involved in a town hall like.
Speaker 2: Isn't this the best? They're going to.
Speaker 1: Hold a town hall to argue.
Speaker 2: Should we use the.
Speaker 1: Methods that the
Democrats are using for fraud or should
we not? But then we hurt ourselves.
Speaker 2: It's unbelievable that
they're doing this to themselves.
Speaker 5: Every state is different.
They're states that Jim will be right
now. That's what we're doing with the bureau.
We're in Biloxi. Look at the footprint of the
state and what's the best thing to do
in that state. Some of these states are
on you can vote a week early, like in
Texas. They don't have a lot of time
to pull from voter rolls.
Speaker 1: And that's so.
Speaker 2: So pillow now is coming.
Speaker 1: Up with a sort of new
conspiracy theory, which is, listen.
Speaker 2: In states where there isn't much early.
Speaker 1: Voting.
Speaker 2: There, it's okay
to vote early because they don't have time to.
Speaker 1: Execute the fraud that they can do
with the machines. When you vote, like really.
Speaker 5: Early, we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 2: So then later.
Speaker 1: Pillow was interviewed
by Right Side Broadcasting and
now he is calling this the new Big lie.
Speaker 5: Now, let me tell you the big lie. The
new big lie. Yeah. And this comes from Republicans
and it's most of it's the establishment. But
there's a few people in our in here that's still
there because of what happened in Arizona. They
believe this. What happened is everyone saying
and this is I even the RNC, when I was there
running for the chair, they're going, we've got
to do like the Democrats vote early. Look what
happened in Arizona. What if something goes wrong
with the machine? We got to vote early and ballot
harvesting and drop boxes and we don't. If you
can't fight them, join them. If you do that, we
lose our country. We have fought two years to do
same day and get rid of these machine. Two years
you're going to destroy everything we fought for.
Speaker 1: Now, the funny thing is, Pillow has
been fighting for two years, but they're not
any closer to getting rid of early voting and
mail in voting. This is fantastic and this is the
exact type of fight that we should allow them to
have amongst themselves while we just remember,
hey, let's vote. Let's let's vote however it is,
because these stories about widespread election
fraud have not been substantiated in the least.
But we want them wasting their time with this
sort of nonsense because it's a black hole for
them. It's a complete and total black hole.
Speaker 2: Hold town halls, do all of it.
Speaker 1: Argue about whether or not to vote
early. Meanwhile, we'll just keep trying to get
people registered and convincing people about
the importance of voting in the first place.